la santé avec ce changement en matière
de médecine esthétique la chirurgie n'a
plus la cote
elle aurait enregistré une baisse de 10
à 20% cette année
l'alternative de plus en plus c'est le
laser efficace mais plus discrets
terminé semble-t-il les opérations qui
fige et déforme les visages
raffermissement effacement ou épilation
le laser prend le pas sur le bistouri
estelle colin olivier robert éviter les
interventions lourdes et coûteuses
quitte à prendre un abonnement chez le
médecin esthétique tout est bon pour
gagner dix ans il y avait mais c'est
votre affaire me citer en fait outre les
injections de botox et d'acide
hyaluronique le laser semble rallier
tous les suffrages
les yeux protégés des risques de brûlure
commence alors le traitement visons à
solliciter la production naturelle de
collagène au final une peau légèrement
repulper ils sont une stimulation du
collagène un peu plus en profondeur
qu'ils soient réels et qui se manifeste
après plusieurs séances et plusieurs
semaines de traitement tout dernier
champ d'application du laser l'ovale du
visage longtemps traitée par lifting un
acte chirurgicale sous anesthésie locale
visant à détruire les cellules
graisseuses tout en optimisant les faits
de rétraction de la peau
coût de l'intervention de 1500 euros va
coaguler les vaisseaux au fur et à
mesure dans cette zone qui est
définition visible exposé un curieux
tous donc les suites sont très simples
sans ecchymoses et beaucoup plus rapide
qu'à être unie prospère son
conventionnelle j'avais un double menton
l'ovale du visage n'était plus très net
et je pensais que le la
r c'était une alternative plus douce à
la chirurgie mais l'indication la plus
courante reste l'épilation dite
définitive plébiscité par les plus de 30
ans la tige du poil et brûlé
et à l'intérieur le but est éclatée
on déduit le but
la facile du poil lorsque l'on démarre
les séances d'épilation laser
il faut cinq à six séances sur un an
coût total de l'investissement près de
700 euros pour les demies jambes
traitement quasi indolore
ça pique un peu selon les endroits par
exemple s'applique davantage en bas de
la jambe quand je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais globalement ça fait pas mal
les traitements que les américains
appellent lunch treatment parce que on
peut les faire à l'heure du déjeuner et
retourner au bureau ni vus ni connus
sont en progression en moyenne de 20 à
30% par an et ce auprès des deux sexes
malgré la crise